hello my name is bono I'm a rock star
sorta and yeah I think there's something
everybody can do and I won't tell I
won't tell you where you can hook up to
fight against extreme poverty in your
own neighbor because I don't know what
the organizations are but you can find
the Matt but I will say this in 2008 if
we were to get anywhere on the fight
against extreme poverty or the climate
crisis we have to prove that we can keep
the promises that we've already made so
we call them the Millennium Development
Goals and right now
politicians are slipping back in their
commitments to have extreme poverty by
2015 so my message to you today is do
not let them and I love that line Tom
Friedman's by climate change don't
change your light bulbs change your
leaders thank you